the last thing that I tested for before
I got mad tv was Smallville I went to
the studio for Pete
are you serious yeah yeah because I was
also rep by Tolan Robbins for management
wow so like they were heavily involved
in that obviously and and and went there
and then yeah they and then they changed
changed the casting Dynamic for those
roles yeah
um but yeah so like that was I you know
that was a crazy small world we could
have been working together yeah we could
have had seven years together I know I
know actually Pete left I think after
two or three years okay they let him go
had enough yeah well I think that the
character I didn't think they were going
anywhere with the character sure you can
only go like oh my
doubt so many times yeah